well it's only a 40-minute talk so the
only covers so much my name is Casey
Clements
I am consulting quantitative engineer
with anaconda my background is in
pricing and trading interest rate
exotics so I apologize basically right
up front to the varying backgrounds to
the people that are here whether you're
familiar with the math sides of things
or with the data sides or interest in
this field basically this is sort of a
pet project of mine so working in banks
Python is basically become the standard
language everybody is using Python
inside of banks but despite this there's
really just a few open source packages
available for us and particularly around
pricing and risk management so few shout
outs basically the existing libraries
quanto peein DX analytics and open gamma
so quantonium they're all kind of
different they all focus very much on
different things so I quanto peon really
focuses on investment strategies and
doing time series analysis hopefully
every one of you are familiar with their
stuff it's very cool DX analytics other
guys that you quant live when you look
deeply into it it's very money xx Carlo
simulation based the all the
sensitivities to various movements in
the market are bump and repress so it's
pretty straightforward and simple and
then all began was the company that I
worked for before I joined mmm before I
joined anaconda and to my knowledge is
the first attempt at an open source
companies ever tried to do to make money
out of creating a package for pricing
and risk that truly was at the edge of a
leading edge of what banks are using
internally and so the intention well
first of all so that was in Java and so
I wouldn't recommend to be honest
anybody really that wants to get deeply
into doing maths to use Java again
that's very much my own opinion we had
to build a lot of stuff from scratch and
one of the reasons why I thought is so
fantastic is that you can you know
bootstrap off the shoulders of giants
and work from all the existing open
source packages for doing science
so really if you don't succeed in the
first time do it again so basically I'm
trying my best to bring in my free time
some sort of cutting-edge package to do
real pricing risk that can be adopted
both by macro hedge funds to investment
banks instead of the you know typically
build stuff in-house and you know
although idea of it isn't to be a toy
for education of course it is an
entry-level thing that people can use to
get kind of they're interested in the
field and that they learn more they you
know I show up to interview etc then
they're ready to go and then finally
because Python Python deserves all the
best so the structure of this talk I'm
gonna be begin it's because I don't know
the background of people with a
quantitative finance crash course the
reason is to motivate the importance and
develop the core building blocks which
are curves for discounting and forwards
I apologize as I said to to focusing on
this quite a bit and the reason that I'm
doing it kind of disclaimer is that
because I do this as a side project I
haven't got full spread and what I
decided to do was like start from the
ground up and so where what I have right
now is really this kind of course start
and then we can build models on top of
that so it's really at this place now
that I got all the cores then I'm going
to actually talk to people and show it
you know what's kind of before private
and so I'll give a quick look through
the package just the structure of it and
then at the end I'm going to show it
notebook highlighting some of the work
that I've done to extend some of the
woofster stuff inside of Syfy's
interpolate to capture specifically risk
that we do in finance so the basics
finance basically is really the study of
boring and lending money right in
particular finance what you're studying
in schools is about the study of
contracts on contingent claims so
contingent claim means that you're going
to get a certain payoff depending upon
what happens events that happen in the
future so this little picture is sort of
what I use in teaching a lot which
basically it's showing that these swaps
off the solid lines heading upwards are
going to be cash flows that you're
receiving where you know what the
payoffs going to be the ones facing down
little squiggly
dependent upon some sort of event in the
future happening and then these X's here
are options so basically what you're
looking at here is a picture of us
swaption so Bermudan option where starts
getting cash flows are being traded back
for and then you have an option periodic
option to basically break the contract
so these are basically the fundamentals
of the exotic swaps desks where I used
to work so basically all three of the
components that I've shown above here
what's the fix and contingent cash flows
as the end the options I'll basically
share the same Foundation which is the
discount bond I'm so really when a lot
of oils down to in finance is how do we
calculate the value of a dollar
at some future time T so let's go
through this so what banks basically do
is lend money as I mentioned before so
as such most of the products look like a
bond and in particular it's going to be
you have some sort of coupon which
basically they pay interest and so for
periodically you fix you borrowed some
money and then periodically they pay
back interest until the principal is
paid back so this form that you see here
where you have like two dates and then
one kind of has some sort of sense of
you're you're accruing interest over
this period and then it kind of gets
paid and some coupon is pervasive so
even if you're not in interest rates
because everything's sort of structured
on the back of bonds the same form shows
up in FX credit even structured equity
there's a lot of things are built very
much to look like this and the options
embedded and some various loan
structures look like that okay so am i
saying here what I really want to say in
this part is I don't know if anybody was
here at Alex Samuels talk if you weren't
I recommend taking a look at it what he
did is he spent a lot of time focusing
on time and the meaning of time and
Python is quite complicated there's
scientific time there's issues of of
time zones he focused a lot on that
there's different libraries within
Python to deal with it now Finance has
its own concept of time and I probably
rebuilt three times basically different
calendars to extend dates so as we saw
here before we have four dates even in
the simple little coupon d'Este
are the start and end dates of which
interest is actually accruing and then
your F is when whatever event was that
makes this kind of payoff determine and
then the TP is when these things
actually paid so basically where this
calculation about like what do you do
with fixing what do you do when you land
on a weekend or holiday anything there's
a lot of work involved here let me see
so yeah exactly we try to complicate
everything so as an example if I have
sugar why can't I get out of this thing
let's see if I present one cool if you
do live in this world this is from my
old company this is probably the most
reference kind of link there is for open
gamma because my friend mark and rod has
gone to a great deal of work to kind of
build up all the conventions and write
them all down
it's para memory problem using my normal
key set I'm here but basically down here
which different organizations and
institutions around the world decide to
count how you measure the amount of
interest that gets paid in any day's
time or over the weekends etc and then
after that you've got all the various
indices and this is all the business
date conventions so this is like all the
ways you deal with just very simply if
something lands on a holiday all these
have different rules and they're very
subtle or every institution every
country gets the right to have their own
to change it and all the things that
Alex talked about oh okay
this is my baby he's six months old
thank you
oh my god and now it's not even changing
why is my computer frozen on this thing
hmm
I literally don't know what to do no
okay well that's good business okay so
I'm gonna quickly go through that's
basically the most basic coupon that we
have is the fixed coupon and most
importantly the value of this is that it
literally looks like what's the value of
a dollar in the future this next one is
the floating coupon the reason I'm going
to go through this is it reforms the
backbone of a lot of the things that
were pricing I'm gonna quickly pass
through this we have a lot of time so in
particular there's something called the
London interbank offering rate and so
this is a polling rate that banks come
up with which gives a sense of like if
we're gonna lend money to you for some
fixed term three months or six months
what is the value that you would lend to
that now although all the derivatives
are based upon this rate it actually
isn't isn't actually traded mark you
know actively at all so when we start to
then build up discounting curves to get
a sense of how much money am I gonna pay
for a dollar in every different dates in
the future we have to come up with some
sort of thing based upon something
that's not traded so we do that by
basically inferring the prices of things
that are actively traded where I'm going
with this
now basically strategy which everything
works in finance it's suppose that in
order to prices floating coupon which
has this payoff of R which is this LIBOR
rate over whatever we've counted to be
the accrual period the idea is if I have
a dollar
at TS then I can invest that dollar at
the end of the period I'm gonna have 1
plus R times tau whatever that thing is
so if I have a dollar there and it's
gonna pay it off there what I end up
with is an extra dollar at the end so
something able to send this around just
a simple hedging strategies that at the
end of this period I want to produce RT
I have an extra dollar so the idea is I
sell a bond that's gonna produce a
dollar at the end and the value of this
coupon here is just the value of the
bump on the beginning and the value of
the quantity n so this is kind of what
you'll see
schools unfortunately it's not what we
get to do but this is the course the
basis so the idea is that this coupon is
just basically the difference of two
zero months sort to zero bond as was the
other one previously and so when we talk
about forward prices I'm just gonna
bring this up so we're going the idea
that the forward price is it is an
agreement basically to trade an asset in
the future for some fixed fixed price
net so we make an agreement for how much
this thing is worth such that we would
trade it with zero money being prayed at
the future time currently a close to
zero price reason I write this down is
because I'm motivating importance of so
this is the value for a forward contract
[Music]
so swap says we've kind of seen now are
just these sums of these two coupons and
so far from what we've seen this is the
only asset that's really traded in the
market you can't get access to anything
else even though it's these discount
bonds that I need to price anything so
basically as I said once we have our
core set of assets and we figured out a
curve we can then price anything we need
to so in library I've build you're gonna
arbitrarily choose what type of interest
rate you're going to use in this case
I've chosen just one that continuously
compounds which is beyond this talk the
importance of that is such that the
derivative of that with respect to the
underlying rate is just the time itself
the data itself times the discount upon
itself so going through this the reason
that gets complicated is that at the top
you've met a vanilla swap is what I
talked talked about so far when I shown
before the difference between one
floating coupon was just the coupon bond
at the beginning - coupon bond at the
end
whether it has a different frequency so
the issue here with pricing is that this
is called a basin swap basically you're
trading to everything this could be two
different currency growth could be two
different different frequencies the
point is even the textbook pricing if
you only pricing up a single curve this
thing shuffle should have a zero value
but if market it trades with a spread so
that when you actually pay this one side
of it so if you want to actually price
any derivatives that have a sensitivity
to say three months grade another six
months right pretty much have to
introduce two different curves so this
is just motivating why this is more
complicated than what textbooks are
let's see okay so jumped a little bit
here but situation is that you're
pricing a bunch of things that have cash
flows at arbitrary dates and we have a
set of curs that we want a price and
these curves have kind of nodes on them
so again in the simplest case you
haven't know where ever you're gonna
need a discount price but for bracing is
at the valuable portfolio it has a whole
bunch of arbitrary times when it
actually is being paid and so in reality
you're gonna have to do a big
calibration exercise where you then gets
a value of those coupons by interpolate
okay so what we're gonna do now is both
calculate different curves and also
calculate how to interpolate them so
what this really comes down to is a big
problem in multi-dimensional route
finding with interpolated values within
there so I get this big Jacobian matrix
which is value it's gonna be the present
value of some sort of derivative with
respect to this case one curve so I'm
using one curve it forwards another
curve to calculate discount rates and so
when you're sitting at the top is
basically the derivative of the price
with respect to the curve itself what I
need to do that I need to basically sum
up the value of the derivative with
respect to the actual so I gotta back
with one of the left is the actual price
compared to the value of the price of
the contracts
and then on the right it's the value of
the contract to the actual curve itself
right so where this is the interpolation
that comes out now again I'm kind of
wrapping up this little crash course but
the important thing here is that we have
a choice for the value of these four
words as a form that looks like this the
different forward rate and strike zero
which means that I have the option to
get into it at whatever time I need to
make that decision and it shares the
same forward so it looks like a value on
the max of the four when we actually
calculate these things we're basically
taking some of these things more
probabilistic the perspective of what
the distribution is again kind of beyond
this talk but the reason I spend so much
time on this on the library that I have
on this particularly it's because
regardless of the market that you're in
so I've so far been focusing on caplets
and swaptions which are kind of the
derivatives of the interest rate world
the same reasoning applies to the equity
world to the FX world to a great deal
the credit world as well so in an equity
the exact same story here where it's a
entering into a contract where I pay a
certain strike in the future in order to
receive the asset so in an equity I
receive one share of that stock in the
future and that becomes my equity
forward when I walk through it and I
won't go through these details and you
can generalize this as well for things
that pay dividends quite simply the pv
of the forward contract looks the same
so it's the forward - the strike times
this discounting factor as long as we
get that forward we understand basically
how to calculate the value from this
from the swap price and the expected
income we need to have the discount
curve properly and then we can extract
to our forwards so now that we have the
kernel for pricing and so once you have
that kernel you then you can use a tree
or a PDE Montecarlo with kind of some
special pieces or you can to some sort
of derivative where we're probably a
distribution which is kind of a stunning
black black Scholes and
models that are kind of smile models if
you're kind of familiar with this stuff
and interest rate bags sorry and it's
the same thing with the effects rate so
basically when you're looking at FX
products the asset in this case is it is
a one unit of the foreign currency
alright so it's how much do I pay in the
current currency to get the foreign
currency and in this case once again we
showed the exact same form just to
motivate this idea is that once I put
this on a Herculean effort into doing
the calibration of this thing for the
discount curves I now have a consistent
framework where I can price a portfolio
of equity affects interest rate products
in different currencies and with
different spreads so as you might
imagine this is kind of what's necessary
now and in particular those spreads that
we were looking at after the financial
crisis of 2008 became non significant so
I'm sorry came significant they used to
be kind of in a place where people could
just wave their hands and get so doesn't
v-0 we can no longer do that it's gotten
quite expensive ok so that's my crash
course in finance I'm gonna move on to a
little tour of the package and then
finally a note book highlighting what
I've had to do to overcome this so oh I
know I mean this weird look at that
sweet we're luck okay so the package
itself is available on github I'll send
a list well it's just that Casey
climbing slash panties you should be
able to do a search on it can we see
that name
let's see I should I do it
oh that's not good okay well I'll see
where we can go basically I have a set
of curves and then I build up with on
these curves that tear away to do it I
apologize
the job of any sort of curve is to
provide a discount factor as you start
building these things up I kind of got
two simple examples one just a constant
but more importantly the one that we end
up using is I just don't curve with
notes so basically you have some pieces
which has n number of kind of nodes in
it and then your interpolate to get any
validates beside that now it's all
relatively bog-standard pieces except
for in here once you get to form and
you're just basically asking for rates
again kind of have it set up in such a
way to keep your prior to date where you
can provide it the time from today and
some sort of your fractional sense which
becomes quite useful when you're
simulating in time or doing back testing
and as I showed before because we're
interpolating things with a specific
form which is continuously discounting
you have this kind of flexibility to do
that then I get really nice setups for
the derivatives around this okay so
thanks really quite simple really and I
apologize you guys can't all see this
that are you set up basically a that's
what I've basically done at this point
is set up a bunch of assets what I've
needed to do which is this one bond that
we've been talking about and then the
various bond prices themselves so an
annuity basically is just a fixed
payment I said of them which becomes
well the core of swaps and the fixed
side and then so I have so far what I've
built and I'm kind of showing what's
there and what's not I'm quite happy to
anybody work with me on this so I have a
fixed leg and a floating leg and the
real core of what I've been doing here
is in the curve calibration pieces so I
won't go through it too deeply except
for that the key to this thing is you're
creating the Jacobian
I mean CS is worth actually going
through again okay so this is my one
little rant about my one rant about why
Python is awesome is that so what I've
done is I've had to like do the all the
work such that I build up pricing
functions for all these various legs
feel what's coming down to a base of
discount factors and then also pseudo
discount factors which is basically fake
discount curve it you're using to
project the forward curves just kind of
the way this is set up and then so once
I've set up the kind of a Jacobian which
is the derivative of the price with
respect to these various rates all the
real hard work is being done by
optimized so the really nice thing is
that you know real hard work which we
had to do in Java was actually to build
the route finder and build this
optimization here it's just coming from
size update so I mean this is why
writing this in Python has been so much
better than than writing it in writing
in Java so let's take a look okay so how
much time do I have anybody know it is
excellent 305 okay cool so what you're
looking at here is Jupiter lab so
basically that what I said in finance we
in finance we use curves all the time
basically the main thing we do and in
order to kind of set these things up we
have this Jacobian that we've seen
before so basically what I care about is
calculating the sensitivity to some
random part on the curve with respect to
the motions and all of the points in the
curve so what I'm gonna do is some
boilerplate stuff here as an example I'm
basically just gonna have a function
which is a sinusoid in and then plot it
so at this point here so this is what
Syfy is basically doing in order to in
order to fit the curve so not
surprisingly is
do a very good job of actually
interpolating the curve but more more
interested in in finance is what's
called the dynamics right so it's like
how do things work as they move forward
in time so what I'm doing here is I've
set things up in such a way which I
haven't done a particularly go over
explaining that when you the sorry the
PDE that gets solved in order to fit a
cubic spline is basically on two
assumptions why was the first derivative
is smooth for all the points and the
second one is that the second derivative
is also continuous through all the
points and then you make adjustment
based upon the extraction elation and
condition so what I've had to do in
order to set this thing up let me just
show really what I'm kind of trying to
do so let's say of some arbitrary point
sitting here I want to know that if any
of these curves moves up by like a small
fraction how it's gonna affect the value
here so in a cubic spline for example
you can move any point over here and
it's gonna have long effects so if you
have a piecewise linear whole idea why
we like piecewise linear is because the
value in the middle only depends upon
these two points so it's quite local
whereas every cubic spline it's very
distributed right so the idea is you
want to have this nice curve and it's
nice something that's closely bound the
dynamics makes sense without having too
much funkiness right so this is what
we're trying to do is and the way you
need to do that is solve an FTE saying
that right solve it yeah it's using
finite difference basically the way
that's done is using route inside of sci
fi optimize and but what I've had to do
to do it is to basically create an
additional dimension so what I'm
basically stopped doing is solving a
stack of peas so what I'm doing is to
calculate the derivative of each one of
these points then what that allows me to
do and is then see so I basically
calculate the sensitivity of these guys
and as you might imagine these shows
back so basically if I calculate the
value what I have these curves on is
every 0.5 so I'm putting my curves at
22.5 etc so if I bump a curve itself I
the sensitivity to be identical so I've
mom multiplies this thing what's the
value of a unit move independent node
you're gonna expect that but you know it
back and then nothing else move so it's
kind of a nice property to make sure
that it's a simple case the same thing
is true for another node however if you
get in the middle then you start seeing
with these curves is that you get these
wave effects right so you're gonna get
close to a half move through the two
points around the center cuz I'm
following this point but basically if I
move any of these points over here it's
gonna have an impact by the long edge of
my curve all these things are gonna move
themselves so important piece of this if
you're kind of following along with that
is that once you have these curves built
up I can then calculate the value of
sensitivity to any one of my any one of
the assets in a portfolio once for the N
number of curves and then I can get
pricing and Delta risk for all the
various pieces within that so kind of my
big I had to get this thing right I
guess really where the stock is going to
a large degree is that before I was
gonna show this to anybody which I'm
kind of proud of it but now only at this
point I can now start plugging models
into it so for anybody that's interested
in modern finance by all means come and
talk to me and we'll figure out how to
plug in more model we've done the hard
work here which is to make make sure
that we can calculate all our forwards
and then we can calculate all the
discounting factors from here we can
then really look at the expectation
which is the distributions of how these
models work and once you've got that
you've got a core so I mean if you look
at something like all you're gonna have
for this it's like some constant
typically it'll be like e to the minus
RT like you see in black Scholes
calculate the four is gonna be you know
s times e to the RT whereas in this case
you have a rigorous foundation for being
able to calibrate too and instruments
and then be able to get portfolio
pricing and risk on a solid foundation
so what I'm hoping to achieve here is to
get started at least this is kind of
baby steps in the real world you know
the open source world to be able to
provide something there's a good
representation realistically
of what investment banks were using and
build up on a solid footing that's it
any questions system I haven't done any
of the data wrangling that was talking
somewhere else so I mean having gone
through that like with the last company
I have a bell from JAMA there's a
significant amount of work and if you're
lucky enough to be in an IV you've got
systems that are pushing these through
and as you know that's a very
significant piece the good news is that
the Python infrastructure has done a
pretty good job of bringing those things
in so the things that we use in finance
all the time the main open source
libraries are things like patents things
that you can sub get out
thanks but they're not really about
pricing but they are about data
wrangling so all the data science pieces
in using in all sorts of different
industries and but the same ones that
can be applied
let's bring a very small there
well it's exactly what this is right
so I mean the Kathy's are all about
continued cash flows so these are we
have to may see of a funding curve which
basically tells you how much fixed value
is the dollar in the future and then you
also have you know the pseudocode which
basically allows you to build forward
rates and it's forward rates I mean if
they're in hjm they're kind of like a
continuous one over a certain spot but
in these kind of market rate so you got
you have these three-month various
eyeball rates which apply through all of
in currencies and then as I showed
previously you can build models for
equity that have the same underlying for
funding curve and then you also can
build up a model inside of that for
dealing with complications to come arise
like importantly with like events like
income and dividend which kind of like
yep build in so they all sort of get
wrapped around this the FX as well if
you basically the framework for this
allows you to do solve curves in two
different currencies so for example
you're gonna have Miller curves in both
currencies and they're gonna have some
sort of a currency basis which is
typically a swamp sopa flowing which is
flowing in two different currencies so
that set up as well so in this case you
can try it you can price FX instruments
as well as interest rates and both of
individual privacy so was there
something else that you had in mind
oh I mean I Luda that's a little bit in
the beginning like I've spent far more
time than I ever wanted to looking at
contracts etc and so as I said is a fair
amount of degree with building schedules
right so we talked a little bit about
that I put a little bit of effort into
figuring out how to hack pandas and
various these pieces to start providing
end dates and beginning dates and
building up these schedules and again
just like we started well it's measuring
time measuring how to deal with dealing
with dates that end up on weekends etc
similar there's different rules about
whether you start from the back forward
whether it's dub so so far it's
relatively vanilla doesn't have stub
rates doesn't have a lot of so many
funky things but coming from a world of
structured finance myself it's most of a
lot of its four building blocks further
here so please yeah jump in and let me
know what issues whatever what do you
think is valuable please good ok thanks
for everyone for listening